Let me show you a picture of softmax function.
And they're very similar in that they are.
used for
assigning to every
feature distribution
a
class in the case of sigmo. It will
be a binary classification.
And the case of softmax it will be.
multi-class classification
but we have this s looking curve.
and if a feature is
You know below the threshold.
it will be given zero if it's binary and
one otherwise
Let me first begin with.
a binary example
And then we can generalize it for multi-class classification.
So before I talk about softmax, let me talk about
sigmoid first because it's easier to talk about.
It's easy to derive the sigmoid function because it's binary.
And the prerequisites are this.
I'll just take you to this other application I've built.
I used to you sometimes users for teaching
it's called a box map.
They bring us over here.
Okay. So these are the people in order for us
to understand the sigmoid function otherwise known as expert. These are
the prerequisites.
So I'm going to open each box.
and quickly take you through the
the
explanation the sigma function is given by this formula.
So, let's see what this is. Why why this
Okay, so let's see. Let's get this derivation.
first of all, if the number of probability is a
number between a real number between 0 and 1
so
and it's given by this number is given by a ratio.
It is the total outcomes.
In the denominator and the chosen outcomes
on the numerator. So for example, let's consider flipping a coin.
or flipping
two coins
and you want to know what is the probability of getting either heads
and tails or two tails or two heads?
The total number of outcomes are these three you
can get two heads two tails or one has
entails and this is a combination not a permutation so
we don't care about the order of the coin.
So it doesn't matter if you get it tells their heads or head to tell
with the same thing.
And you want to know what is a probability of getting two tails?
Well you well, there's only one.
such
outcome
from your total number of outcomes. So that's one over three
or 33%
if we can round it up to 34% if you want.
The chance of getting it tails on the Tails when you
flip two coins.
Is 33%
that's probably
okay.
A several example is flipping one coin. How many
outcomes you have? You only have two heads or tails. So what is
it probably of getting ahead?
50%
your total number of outcomes is two and then your chosen
outcomes one. So 1 over 2. That's 50%
Of course, assuming you have a perfectly balanced coin.
Then we have odds.
Odds is a is the ratio of two probabilities.
For example, you want to know what is the probability of getting a
let's say you have two people who are very
making a bet.
And we want to know who has a higher probability of winning the
bet.
One person bets on getting a tails and a
tails the other person gets bets on getting either heads or
heads.
or heads and tails
so they have
a higher probability because they have more
the their number of chosen outcomes is greater.
And you might say this is unfair. Well so are
many so is the real world, right? So for example in horse betting
people who can buy more bets have more number
of outcomes if they better more horses naturally have
a higher probability of winning.
Whereas if I buy if I put all my money on one horse. Well, I
have a smaller problem and that's that's what odds is
the odds of that. Let's say you have bet on three horses
or in this case. Let's say it's two because we
have your number of choice. Your number of outcomes is
closed the total number of outcomes.
You'd have a higher probability. So if you compare you're probably versus
my probability, that's the odds ratio.
The odds would be in your favor you would have
twice.
The odds of you winning is twice as high.
We'd also the probability is how you say the odds
is twice as high.
because if we divide your probability over my probability
we will get to
okay.
now
another way to express the same ratio.
is to
Take my probability and subtract it from
one. Why because well
there are three outcomes three three possible outcomes. I
have taken one of them.
So there are two remaining.
So out of the 100% of the outcomes I have
taken.
33% of it
That's what 1 minus 3 is. Oh, that's why
we have one minus P TT. So if
I had no
if you are taking all three.
Outcomes you would have 100% probability of
winning because you have bet on all three outcomes. But if I
take one of them you have one less than the entirety.
That's why we have one minus PTT. Either way. You will get
the same number.
Okay. Now why do we want to re-express the
problem the express the odds ratio in this way because this is
going to bring us to log on.
the log odds is about taking the
now if you see here what we have
done is we have inverted.
the ratio
Okay. So this was P of X in the
denominator and 1 minus P of X in the numerator here.
We've just flipped it. I just
a reversed in the previous example this you can understand the Arts
and the anal index and the analogy of two people betting and
one has
they have the luxury of more chosen outcomes
than the other person.
but if we flip it around
we will get
We will still have the ratio but we
have a problem.
the reason we use logarithm
In any context of probability, so there's something called likelihood and
maximum likelihood you may have heard of this. The reason
we use a lot of rhythmic function is to change
the scale of the probability. You see the number can
be very small if I have for example
0.05 probability over
let's say
1 minus P of X will be
1 minus.
0.5.
You see the probability is very small.
0.5%
and
in the case of multi-class classification, you will
have all of these very tiny properties 5% 1% less
than 1%
So for arithmetic purposes and in particular competition purposes
We want to kind of rescale.
The probability so for example, if I take 5% and
I put it in the logarithmic function and the base of
the logarithm is not really important. I have changed the scale.
So it's not one point negative 1.3.
Okay, so really what I want to get across is
this the choice of the base is not that important.
But we want to apply the log rhythmic function just to
change the scale. And of course log base of e is just the natural
log with natural logarithm.
Okay.
Then we have the logite function. The logite function is really that when
you apply the logarithmic function to your odds,
that's where you call the logit function.
So let me zoom out.
So the expression we saw previously, that's the logic.
And it turns out when you evaluate this
expression it is the same thing as evaluating beta
Subs 0 and Beta Support. Now, what is better
Sub Zero better sub one.
These are the coefficients.
of the regression model
so
did I reference to the regression model anywhere else?
Not here.
So let's move this up here.
And for Simplicity, let me remove the other.
Variables and let's just say we have two.
You have two variables.
The Epsilon is the residual.
That's the error rate. Let me not include that
in here either just really keep it simple.
and let's just have beta sub 1
so beta Sub Zero is what we call the bias term.
Or the Y. It's the number of the Y intercept
so in the value function the bias or the x-axis in
the general regression model devices and the
y axis.
This is the y-intercept.
and this is the
x sub one is the feature and this
is its weight.
Now we talking we'll talk about real estate signs of
the property number of bedrooms, etc. Etc.
X sub one is one feature and
beta sub one. It's it's the weight associated with the correct
weight associated with it.
Okay.
That's where beat is up 0 and better someone come from.
so if we return this the logic function
the
Numerical value that we'll get from a validity this expression
is the same as that expression.
If we apply if we want to get rid of the logarithm if you
want to change the scale again.
We will have to take this expression.
And to raise it to the exponential function
to cancel to eliminate log.
And that's what we do here.
We've taken the expression above.
And raise it to e but that mean but this is
algebra. So we have to do it other side as well.
Then of course e to the power log e will get eliminated.
and this expression
whoops this expression comes down here.
Now in order to derive the sigma function, we have to do some allergy break
manipulation.
Which is going to be a multiple steps to what I'm going to do is I'm going to avoid that instead what I've
done.
is I have
created
if you can go to symbol lab what you looked at before to basically
move one minus P of x to the other
side and then after a little bit of algebraic manipulation.
We get this.
This is the formula. Basically this is
odds. This is the odds.
In the context of binary classification we're asking what is
the what is the probability of it being this
class versus being in that class? What is that?
Probably of being of this particular?
feature
being fraud versus not front. What is
a odds of this being?
Well, actually probability so we have taken the concept of
odds and we have now representing as making it
a probabilistic number. So what is it now the probability of
being a Spam versus the probability of not being spam. What
is it? What is the probability of it being?
An animal versus that probably of it not being in that's the
idea here.
Okay.
so this was very
sped up.
explanation of
the sigboid function
So what do we will do is then every time we get a feature?
it will be a
it's valuable be inside.
The probability of it being in a class versus the probability of
not being in the class.
Okay.
and so that's what
the sigmoid is going to do.
if it can if it goes above the threshold we'll
classified as
Let's see fraud if it falls below the threshold will
classify it as non-front binary classification.
So the observations will end up up here or down here.
Yeah, and apparently sigmoid is a term used
in medicine as well.